estos son los hombres que las
autoridades checas están buscando
identificados como alexander petrov rus
land bus y loft sus nombres coinciden
con los utilizados por los dos
sospechosos del envenenamiento en 2018
del ex espía ruso serguéi skripal y de
su hija giulia en reino unido la
república checa dice que los hombres
estaban en el país en el momento de una
explosión mortal en un depósito de armas
hace siete años y el sábado praga acusó
a los servicios de inteligencia rusos de
estar involucrados en el hecho hay una
sospecha razonable'' la participación de
oficiales rusos de la unidad 21 955 del
servicio de seguridad de la información
en la explosión de los depósitos de
municiones de raptis en 2014 y a prophet
barriles externos en octubre de 2014
varias explosiones sacudieron el
depósito de municiones de arma tis a más
de 300 kilómetros al sureste de praga
matando a dos personas en respuesta a
los resultados de la investigación
anunciados el sábado las autoridades
checas dijeron que expulsaban a 18
diplomáticos rusos
he decidido deportar a todos los
trabajadores de la embajada rusa en
praga que fueron claramente
identificados por nuestro servicio
secreto como miembros del servicio
secreto ruso 18 trabajadores de la
embajada rusa tienen que abandonar la
república checa- dentro de 48 horas
pasar un alto parlamentario ruso
calificó de absurdas las afirmaciones de
praga moscú también ha negado su
implicación en el envenenamiento de
skripal el cual provocó la mayor ola de
expulsiones diplomáticos entre rusia y
occidente desde la guerra fría